another gaming new short for you take to
the company that effectively funds
Rockstar to make Grand Theft Auto just
released some very interesting finances
that might indicate Grand Theft Auto 6
is coming out next year this is a blog
post from their website that talks about
net revenue net bookings basically how
they did financially in the last year
part of that was an investor relations
slideshow that included their outlook
for the beginnings of 2024. they said we
believe that we will enter our next
phase of growth in fiscal 2025 as we
plan to deliver several groundbreaking
titles that we anticipate will set new
standards of quality and success and
enable us to deliver over 8 billion
in-net bookings and over 1 million in
adjusted unrestricted operating cash
flow we expect to sustain this momentum
with additional growth in operating
performance in fiscal 2026. of course
Take 2 does have a pretty big portfolio
of high grossing games at this point
because they also have 2K and they have
Zynga but that amount of confidence tied
with the leaks last year I think it's a
pretty safe bet that we get a new Grand
Theft Auto in 2024 or 2025